y ya lo decía yo las cifras son
alarmantes y justamente la cepal ha
calificado la situación como una
pandemia en las sombras Qué es en lo que
estamos fallando para no ver una mejora
en las cifras de los casos de violencia
contra las mujeres en nuestra región
Bueno buenas tardes Muchas gracias por
la invitación
gente estamos fallando como sociedad
podemos decir porque si bien los estados
bueno están haciendo esfuerzos a las
mujeres nos siguen matando hay un
sistema que es estructuralmente machista
y violento que nos sigue oprimiendo y
nos sigue discriminando y tenemos que
seguir
viviendo en un 25 de noviembre
llorando a miles y miles de mujeres en
la región estamos pasando Considero que
es en una falta de respuestas que sean
multiactor multinivel y multilateral
terminar con la violencia machista es
una decisión política
para lo cual evidentemente es necesario
también que haya presupuesto destinado
para ello sea para la prevención Pero
también es necesario que se estructuran
respuestas en este sentido es decir que
también desde la sociedad civil tenemos
una obligación pero también los estados
lógicamente la tienen señora de Angelo
justamente Ese es el lado de la sociedad
que estamos fallando para revertir estas
cifras Pero entonces falta también mucho
apoyo por parte de las autoridades para
dar garantías a las mujeres que se le
puede pedir entonces a los gobiernos de
nuestra región
bueno los gobiernos de nuestra región
lógicamente son quienes detentan las
obligaciones internacionales que están
bueno dentro de los diferentes tratados
dentro por ejemplo de la convención y
demás pero particularmente en materia de
femicidio lo que vemos es que no
solamente hay una deficiencia por
ejemplo en el sistema judicial y demás
sino que también los estados están
fallando en contabilizar los
feminicidios y cuál es el problema con
esto que si no sabemos específicamente
de cuánto de Cuántas mujeres muertas
estamos hablando y en qué contexto
social solamente cuantitativo sino que
también tiene que ser cualitativo
no podemos no pueden generar políticas
públicas que sean adaptadas que sean
eficientes que sean sostenibles en el
tiempo y que realmente resuelvan el
problema
señora de Angelo viendo las cifras vemos
Que cerca del 4% del total de los
delitos contra las mujeres se cometen
contra menores de 14 años Cuál es
entonces la situación de las menores de
edad que hacen parte de estas
estadísticas en la región de América
Latina
Sí exactamente lo que vemos las cifras
son exactamente esas las que estamos
observando desde las organizaciones de
la sociedad civil Es cierto que en otra
vez en relación a esto Hay un problema
en materia de datos los estados en
general no están relevando esta
información como tampoco están relevando
información interseccional es decir que
no están relevando por ejemplo
información referida a la pertinencia
étnica hacia la mujer o la niña era
migrante o la joven era migrante con lo
cual se está
invisibilizando esta problemática y la
realidad es que también muchos niños y
niñas están también quedando sin madres
no solamente están siendo asesinadas